today on the matt walsh show the media
democrats teachers unions are
are pushing for schools to remain closed
seemingly indefinitely i guess due to
covet
19 but the actual facts about the virus
make it clear that schools can be
reopened should be reopened so what
what's this really about why are they
actually trying to keep schools closed
we'll talk about all that today also
five headlines including bill de blasio
mayor of new york fretting over his blm
mural that was painted on the street
which is really more glorified graffiti
than a mural
fretting over that while babies are shot
dead in his city
um we'll talk about that also today for
our daily cancellation long overdue we
will be canceling
mommy bloggers it's time it needs to
happen
and that's going to happen today um but
beginning with this it's been strange
you know i have to say
because i have been reliably informed
we've all been reliably informed over
and over and over again that our
teachers
our our sainted teachers especially our
public school teachers
are self-sacrificing heroes who care
only about educating our precious
children right we've all heard that okay
equipping the next generation um you
know
getting our kids ready for the future
they're doing the hardest job they're
doing the most important job
and but they're passionate about it they
love doing it they care
they care about our kids right i
remember hearing this
don't you remember that many times in
fact
incessantly even uh until the point of
nausea you might say but now we're being
told
that many teachers don't want to go back
to work they don't want to go back to
school they don't want to educate our
kids
because they're scared of the virus as
the nyt reports in this headline
they are fearful and angry about being
pressured to go back to school
they're making demands as teachers seem
to so often do
the la teachers union has a long list of
demands
that will need to be met before they'll
go back to school
many of them seemingly disconnected
entirely from covid concerns for example
they want to defund the police
that's part of the what does that have
to do with covet who knows apparently
i don't know the police are out there
intentionally
spreading the virus those bastards it's
just yet another thing that the evil
police are doing
um but the the mellow drama from
teachers is really off the charts
newsweek reports that teachers in texas
are writing their wills because they
have to go back to school
uh they're also getting medical power of
attorney established they're they're
taking out extra life insurance policy
this is all according to
what some teachers in the article are
saying um
and these dramatics are echoed by the
media and many other people in our
country
some in the media like jennifer rubin at
the washington post
have flat out said that sending our kids
back to school
is killing them we we are giving them a
death sentence
by sending them back to school that's
what's being argued now
let's look at the actual facts those
pesky things
i'm going to show you some graphs here
and i posted this on my twitter you can
go
there as well i got all this i got all
this information from the american
council on science and health
the cdc the national center for
education statistics and an article in
business insider that's where i get
all these statistics um okay here is the
uh
infection fatality rate for covid by age
all right there's the chart and you see
it's
minuscule for kids school-age kids
from .001
for the youngest set to .0003 for the
middle school to high school bracket
okay that's that that's the mortality
rate for covid
for school age kids now here's the
important point
via business insider the death rate for
the flu
in that same bracket is substantially
higher
still low still very low but
substantially higher
so if you've never said
that sending our kids to school during
flu season is a death sentence and we're
killing them and uh it's a heartless and
cruel thing to do
but you are saying that now about covid
then i have only one question for you
when did you become such a shameless
lying hack
that's my only question see i don't want
to hear this stuff about
oh so you're saying even if the death
rate's point zero zero one
percent you're you're saying that's okay
you're okay with that you're okay with
those kids dying
well that's what you say during flu
season every single flu season that's
what you
by your own logic anyway that's what you
say
as for teachers uh because that's what
this is all really about
we see that the death rate for adults is
also very low until you get to the 50
plus range and then it really skyrockets
at 65 plus and many of those in 65
because 65 plus is a large age bracket
right
um many of those are going to be 75
80 85 years old or older in nursing
homes
and and we know that's one of the
reasons the death rate for for covet
is precipitously declining even as
cases go up and one of the reasons the
case is going up is because they're
testing more for it but
either way the death rate is going down
in this country
you wouldn't know that from all the
hysterics in the media
but it is why is the death rate going
down one of the reasons
is that many of these states as we have
covered as we covered extensively when
it was happening
many of these states intentionally set
covet-infected people into nursing homes
and it just decimated the nursing home
population
um and they're not doing that anymore
after months of doing it finally they've
been shamed
into stopping and what do you know
now that we have actually successfully
protected the nursing home population
the death rate is declining
significantly
um now
okay so that's that's those are the the
the death rates
uh by age group what's the average age
of teachers though
you know do do we have a majority of
65 year old teachers well no the average
age for teachers in america according to
this graft is 42.
only a relatively small minority are in
the highest risk age group
what this means is that the vast
majority of people in a school
from the students to the teachers
administrators
are not at any substantial risk students
especially
and that's probably why the american
academy of pediatrics
issued guidance strongly urging that
schools be reopened
what the american academy of pediatrics
says and this is hardly a right-wing
organization what they say is that it's
it's better for the kids and healthier
and safer for them
if we send them back to school i want to
read a little bit from what the um
the that group has to say but before we
do this show brought to you by blink
sale
revolutionary invoicing software that's
changing the landscape for small
businesses and independent contractors
everywhere
uh you know the the american dream is
owning a small business
you get a lot of freedom opportunity
that comes with that you can you can be
your own boss
live your own life do what you want to
do work for yourself rather than working
for someone else but
many business owners know that there are
so many challenges and hurdles that come
with that
some of the challenges and hurdles you
didn't really anticipate or you didn't
think it'd be a big deal
and they end up being more significant
obstacles than you think one of those
is invoicing if you've ever had to
hassle a client that owes you money or
you've gotten lost trying to keep track
of your invoices
struggling with organization and all of
that kind of stuff you know
uh or you've got the microsoft word
template and
you get the ugly clunky sort of thing
you know how difficult it is
uh to keep track of the invoices and
make them look professional that's why
you need
blink sale blink cell you can send
beautiful custom branded invoices and
estimates in seconds
stay on top of your outstanding invoices
let your customers and clients easily
pay your invoices online
forget about using invoice templates and
stressing about coordinating a bunch of
different software programs just use
blank sale
even better added bonus blink sales
giving away ten dollars to 500 daily
wire fans here's how to get to go to
blinksale.com start your 14 days free
trial
create your first invoice of ten dollars
and activate an online payment option
send the invoice to dailywire
blinksale.com get paid your ten dollars
you can do that
right now stop wasting time invoicing
and try blink sales for free blink sale
dot com
slash walsh that's b l i n k s
a l e dot com slash walsh blink sale
spend less time billing and more time
doing what you love
okay um so let me read this
a little bit this is from the npr report
on the american academy of pediatrics as
the nation's pediatricians have come
out with a strong statement in favor of
bringing children back to the classroom
this fall wherever and whenever they can
do so safely
the american academy of pediatrics
guidance quotes strongly advocates that
all policy considerations for the coming
school year should start with a goal of
having students physically present in
school
the guidance says schools are
fundamental to child and adolescent
development and well-being
the aap cites mounting evidence that
transmission of the chronovirus by young
children is uncommon partly because
they're less likely to contact
contracted
in the first place on the other hand the
aap argues that based on the nation's
experience this spring remote learning
is likely to result in severe learning
loss and increased social isolation
social isolation in turn can breed
serious social emotional and health
issues
child and adolescent physical or sexual
abuse substance use depression and
suicidal ideation that cites as
uh as particular risks now all of this
said
okay are there risks involved in opening
schools well of course there are there
are always risks
there are risks from disease there are
risks from violence there are risks for
all kinds of risks that go
uh with just leaving your house and and
certainly setting your kids to school
there are risks involved with that
but what is the other option okay you
see that's the question that the coveted
fearmongers
have never answered they always avoid
they refuse to answer it
they complain about reopening they go
into their hysterics any times
anytime it happens launching into this
whole dramatic production
but they never explain what they would
prefer to see
happen except in very vague terms
they'll say something like
well it needs to be better that's what i
know
this isn't good we need a better well
what's your plan what should we do
instead
something better that's what we should
do we should have a better thing than
this
that's my idea uh oh very
very very good very helpful thank you
for that
no they won't go into specifics um
they won't they won't lay it out
so i will you know they're not going to
do it so let me do it there are broadly
two options here only two
one is to reopen schools while the virus
is still out there and there's no cure
and to do our best to manage the risks
the other is to keep them closed
indefinitely possibly for years until an
effective vaccine
is ready and available whenever that
happens if it ever happens
that's it okay there there are different
ways of approaching those two options
but those are
the options one way or another it's
going to be some version of one of those
door one or door two
here's the irony most of the people
who go with option two even if they
won't
quite say it um explicitly that
it does appear that option two is what
they want keep schools closed
indefinitely
even if that means for years however
long it takes for the virus to go away
um and by the way before i get that
uh another dodge that you'll hear from
people is to say
well we need to wait until the virus is
under control or we have to wait until
the
the the curve is flattened well we did
cur
we did flatten the curve and we are
getting the virus under control
especially when it comes to the death
rate which is declining
but the point is that whatever we do
even if the curve whatever
magical curve we're talking about if it
goes away if we get it under control
whatever that means in your head
if it's still out there and there's no
cure
then whenever you reopen it's probably
going to
start surging again because it's still
there
so whatever you do to get it under
control by hiding in your house it's
because you're in your house
whenever you leave your house it's still
going to be there and then it's going to
reappear and and it's going to happen
again
the only way to avoid that happening
completely is to just stay in your house
until there's a cure
a vaccine so we go back to really it's
option one rupture
either we are getting back to our lives
when the virus is still
out there or not it has to be one or
that one of those two
right now most of the people that would
apparently go with option two
keep the schools closed indefinitely are
also invariably the people who would say
that the school experience
is vital to the growth of our children
vital to their development and their
maturity and their very lives
so they're willing to potentially give
up on a whole generation of children
give up on their education
because they're scared of getting sick
now think about that the other irony
is that although i am positioning myself
i guess on the reopening side of things
that's not how i feel about it about
about schools and i'll explain how i
feel in just a second but first
i want to tell you about our good
friends over at rock otto you know it
could be very frustrating just to take
hours
uh just to get a simple thing on your
car fixed you know when you think about
you get in your car leave it drive down
to an auto parts store go through that
go through that whole rigmarole
and it just takes a lot longer than it
needs to rockauto.com is a much easier
more efficient
cheaper way to take care of all of this
uh you just go to rockauto.com you have
it at your desk you have it in your
pocket
on your phone rockauto.com always offers
the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts it's really you know that's a
simple question there's no reason to do
it rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years and go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low
uh and the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers i mean the guys at
rockauto.com they're going to
give you the lowest price that it's
possible to do
um and that's what you can rely on when
you go to rockauto.com the catalog is
unique
they got all the different kinds of
parts you could need remarkably easy to
navigate even for someone as stupid as
me
um and uh so it'll be even easier for
you quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brand specifications and
prices you prefer
amazing selection reliably low prices go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car
truck write walsh in there how did you
hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you now
talking about you know sending kids back
to school the irony is that although i'm
i'm you know taking the position of of
of being
in favor of opening them up again i
actually don't think that public schools
are essential to the growth of children
that's not my position i think they're
often an impediment to growth i think
that our education system is a disaster
and it destroys more children than it
helps
so you know i i am here trying to hold
the other side to its own standard to
its
own rhetoric but as far as my own
perspective goes i think kids can do
just fine without the public school
system
um so i'm almost arguing
you know i i'm trying to do a favor for
the other side i guess
it's saying let's get the schools open
because the kids need it
that's what they're supposed to be
saying
the problem though of course is that
when it comes to shutting down the
schools
the real problem is that our whole
society is built around the public
school system
um the broader societal
structure is is is is made
so that it's essential to have free day
care eight hours a day
five days a week nine months a year um
the biggest hurdle then
if you're shutting down schools is to
adjust
to the to the to accommodate the loss of
that daycare system
but as far as the kids themselves and
that is a serious um
problem for a lot of families there's no
uh dismissing or discounting that
you know if you're a two-income family
if you need two incomes to stay afloat
and you can't afford private school
what are you going to do what have you
been doing now i've heard different
things but it's been it has been
a a very serious very hard even
disastrous
time for a lot of families because of
that issue as far as the kids themselves
go
though on the other hand on the matter
of education in and of itself
home school is better for them anyway
so so you know maybe that's the silver
lining here the school system is saying
you don't need us we're not essential
teachers are basically saying
we're not essential employees you don't
need us
well maybe we should take them at their
word maybe we should say okay fine take
the year off
matter of fact take forever off we got
this
and then we go and take charge of our
children's education again
which wouldn't be such a bad thing
now again i i have always been a
proponent
of moving away from the factory assembly
line system of education where we put
all the kids into this
system and you know this cookie cutter
thing that they're supposed to fit into
and we
we stuff 30 kids into a classroom and we
have it handled by government employees
i've always said that we need to move
away from that as a society
now i i think that ideally we move away
from it gradually so that society has
time to adjust and families can adjust
doing it all at once like this can be
disastrous and that's what we're going
through right now
but the point is that the schools are
the ones saying apparently
that our kids don't need them
and leaving aside all the concerns with
you know who's going to take care of
your kids during the day when it comes
to education
i guess my answer is i agree we don't
no matter what happens though last thing
i'll say
please god when the teachers do go back
don't let them start doing tick-tock
dancing videos
please i know it's going to happen but
i'm begging
our our country can't handle it we have
suffered enough
so please anything but that all right
let's move to our uh
headlines for the day before we do that
uh i want to tell you about ready wise
our sponsor wise company have you heard
a lot about they've changed their name
to ready wise
now is a better time than any to be
prepared with long-term nutritional food
options
ready wise has many options like
emergency meals
freeze-dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on-the-go nutrition
they've also got adventure meals for
hiking and camping outdoor activities so
it's not just about being prepared for
emergency it's also about if you like
going outdoors like i do
um it's great to grab a ready-wise meal
as i often do myself ready-wise meals
are easy to prepare
all you got to do is add water and
it's as simple as that they have a very
long shelf life and here's the other
thing i like
about ready wise they use the finest
ingredients the latest food preparation
technology
and so they're going to ensure that you
have optimal taste and freshness as well
every recipe is crafted by a team of
chefs to provide a nutritional meal
during critical times each meal is a
combination of both dehydrated and
freeze-dried ingredients
meals are packed into durable
long-lasting pouches and they'll last
for up to 25 years but the great thing
is
that it actually tastes good um when
you're eating it as well
and you know now is the time to take
responsibility and just be prepared
this week my listeners can get free
shipping at readywise.com when entering
walsh at checkout or by calling
three oh eight 855-475-3089 readywise
has a 90 day no questions asked return
policy so there's no risk taking the
initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today that's
ready wise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e dot com
promo code walsh
to get free shipping uh we're big fans
of freddie wise over here and all of our
sponsors as uh you know we want to thank
all of our sponsors for
continuing to support this show and all
of uh the shows at the
the daily wire during a really difficult
time and we ask you to you know
if if you can if you have it in the
budget you hear you hear about a sponsor
that you like to support those sponsors
as well
let's go to headlines number one bill de
blasio the
big dumb cantaloupe come to life
is overseeing a city that has plunged
into violence and anarchy a baby
a baby was shot in the stomach and
killed a couple days ago
people are dying every day but here's
what he's worried about from de blasio
it
says
to whoever vandalized our mural on fifth
avenue
nice try uh let's see we've already
fixed it the black lives matter movement
is more than words and it can't be
undone
this is what this dumb oaf is worried
about
people are dying left and right he's
focused on the mural on the street
a mural which by the way isn't really a
mural can i just say
words spray-painted on the street are
not a mural
that is state-sanctioned graffiti let's
not let's not
uh do it the favor of calling it a mural
that's not a mural
murals have artistic value that doesn't
but either way artistic value or not um
it doesn't matter no one cares about
your stupid painting
you idiot number two here's a shocking
turn of events a few weeks ago a student
at texas a m claimed that he found
racist
notes on his car um they said all lives
matter
you don't belong here and then another
one had the n-word he posted it online
it went viral media covered it etc etc
and so forth
and then what do you know who'da thunk
terenzatti wrote it himself
i am floored i know you probably are too
who could have guessed
that the old racist note left on the
windshield thing would end up being
fake i mean it's only fake every single
time who who could possibly
imagine that this one would be fake too
um
here's here's how ridiculous it's gotten
that hate crime hoaxes are so common
that there are now genres of them there
are identifiable
recognizable genres and everyone has
their own favorite
right like there's the uh there's the
this one the
racist note left on the car windshield
gambit
there's the racist graffiti oftentimes
sprayed on a garage
um or you know side of a house or
somewhere else there's the
uh racist note on the receipt
the fake racist note on the receipt
that's maybe my personal favorite genre
of of the hate crime oaks
there's of course the racist noose
obviously um
there's the racist uh note on a
starbucks cup is another one
and then there are then there are
sometimes people there's the genre
bending genre defying more ambitious
efforts like the jessie smallette for
example
you know the thing is i appreciate the
justice milletts i do
um to have that ambition and to be a
little bit more inventive
uh although you know you you could argue
that his hate crime hoax was derivative
because all he really did was combine a
few of these other genres and throw them
together
in kind of a grab bag sort of way there
wasn't there wasn't much of a compelling
narrative there um but i appreciated the
effort i guess is what i'm trying to say
but really when it comes down to it uh
my thing is
no reason to get inventive you call me
old-fashioned but i
like these quaint you know a little
cliched
genres uh so if you're gonna go with the
hate crime hoax i say
stick with the classics you know oldies
book goodies
um play the hits that's sort of my way
of looking at it and and
that's what this guy did here you know
he's just he's just doing them you know
going with the standard
note on the car type of thing not a lot
of effort put into it but that's okay
doesn't matter um any other things of
course
people on the left it doesn't matter how
obvious obvious it is
they'll accept it doesn't matter so uh
no reason to put some effort into it and
um
and usually we're good for about one a
week now from from at least one of these
genres
and uh you know it's it's it's a lot of
fun a lot of fun
numbers but but remember america's
systemically racist okay
we have actual genres of hate crimes um
but america's systemically racist right
number three i thought this was a was
also a lot of fun tweet from ilhan omar
says
income inequality is the greatest
determinant of your health and life
expectancy
our economy needs to needs to work for
the many not the few
the really interesting thing is that you
know ilhan omar and the other
people in congress aoc you know other
members of the of the squad
uh as much as they talk about income
inequality and how concerned they are
with it
you know they're making 174 000 a year
as members of congress which is well
over a hundred thousand dollars
more than uh significantly more than
doubled
the the uh the average american salary
so
they could lead by example and call for
congress to impose significant pay cuts
on itself
so that the salaries of of our
congressional members
reflects the average american salary and
then at least you're doing your own part
to solve the income inequality problem
but they're not doing that
funny enough you know they're not
interested in that
it's that's it and also ilhan omar um
she
apparently allegedly has been funneling
hundreds of thousands of dollars
from her campaign to her to her
husband's consulting firm
you know so it seems like she's not only
is she not
doing things to solve the income
inequality problem
but she is going out of her way to
perpetuate that problem
uh by making her own income all the more
unequal to everybody else's
really really strange how it works i
mean it's almost like
it's all but call me crazy it's almost
like these people don't give the
slightest damn about incoming
income inequality at all you know it's
that you would you would almost think
that wouldn't you
number four and as the wheel turns
another name change is being demanded
this is from the washington post it says
uh the texas rangers team name must go
members of the texas rangers force
were violent agents of white supremacy
uh so texas rangers were next to go i
you know i i knew this was coming i saw
this coming
and uh you know what they're saying is
that
texas rangers were you know white
supremacists
uh they were violent men uh they killed
native americans
so on and so forth which which by the
way they were violent men and they did
kill native americans
the only thing that you know oftentimes
is not mentioned
by the people who advocate uh things
like this
is that they were doing battle with um
indian tribes who themselves were
extraordinarily violent and in fact
texas rangers would have been battling
the most violent indian tribes in the
entire country the plains indians the
comanches in particular
uh you know would as as as we talked
about last week
you know par for the course
standard operating procedure for tribal
at the comanches
was to um
invade either neighboring tribes or it
didn't matter if you if you were
it wasn't like they were just lashing
out against
white expansionism no they would they
would treat you whether you were a white
outsider or an indian outsider they
would treat you the same and what that
meant was
invading your village or your tribe um
killing as many people as they could
gruesomely scalping
taking scalps as as souvenirs any men
who were captured would
automatically be tortured to death again
standard operating procedure it was just
understood that's what they would do
uh babies were automatically killed
women were gang raped and then killed
children were taken as uh as enforceably
adopted by the tribe
and this is just how it went for
centuries this is just what they did how
they operated
um and that's what the texas rangers
were up against and they themselves were
violent men it was a violent time
and everybody was violent um
but of course you know the texas rangers
were the undisputed bad guys
somehow even though they're up against
people who are doing some of the most
committing some of those brutally
horrific violent acts
you could imagine and even a lot of
stuff you couldn't possibly imagine
even though that's the case they're
still totally the bad guys 100
and the other side is entirely innocent
right
number five finally johnny depp i guess
is in divorce proceedings with his wife
amber heard
um and i you know i've seen these
headlines pop up i don't really care
except i i did see this i did care about
a little bit i saw this photo was
released today
shown in court it's johnny depp passed
out
covered in ice cream and this is
supposed to prove i don't know that he's
uh that he's a monstrous
figure i'm i'm not sure i just want to
say in his defense
okay who has not fallen asleep covered
in ice cream
we haven't we all been there this is me
three times a week
i mean my wife definitely has found me
on the couch late at night with a plate
of food
asleep head hanging down like that and
the food just
falling off into my lap i'm not high i'm
not on drugs okay i'm not drunk it's
stone cold sober but you know it's it
happens you go for the late night snack
it's midnight you're tired and you fall
asleep in the middle of eating am i the
only one maybe i am maybe it's just me
and johnny depp
also a slightly more serious note i
suppose i keep seeing these pictures
of johnny depp in these compromising
positions
what kind of wife i have no dog in this
fight at all um i don't even understand
what the fight is i mean it's a divorce
okay i guess that's pretty
self-explanatory but
what kind of wife takes pictures of
their
husband like you you find your husband
in a compromised position
and you take a picture of him that's
your first reaction
you're really concerned about his health
and so you take pictures of them
and save those pictures and now you
bring them out in court yeah that's
real real loving and attentive life
there uh he had for himself i suppose
let's go to our daily cancellation it's
a very important one well they're all
important but this one especially
before we do that you know in the midst
of all this news ben shapiro has a new
book
called how to destroy america in three
easy steps
uh he must have seen into the future
when he was writing this thing because
it's come to life all around us
very timely book the book goes on sale
tuesday july 21st at 6 pm eastern 3 pm
pacific
and ben will be doing a virtual live
signing event on the day of the release
with your purchase of a signed copy you
can write in a question which
maybe you read and answered as you
signed your books the book covers two
fundamentally different visions of
america that are now on the table one
vision is unifying and finds unity in
our shared philosophy and culture and
history
the other disintegrates our country in
the name of fundamental change
disintegrationists
also use weapons like cancel culture
deleting or silencing anyone who
disagrees
to further build their their new world
order
how to destroy america in three easy
steps details how this alternate world
view has gained so much cultural ground
so quickly
uh it's you know we talk about timely
books it doesn't get more timely than
this so
make sure to buy that book you can
pre-order it now um
but also remember dailywire.com ben to
order your signed copy and join
ben's live signing on tuesday july 21st
okay today for our daily cancellation
something long overdue we're gonna be
canceling mommy
bloggers all of them they needed to be
canceled years ago
i think it's probably too late for
intervention at this point but someone
has to try because the entire mommy
blogging genre is vapid and toxic
family and brain cell destroying
um it mostly consists of women
complaining about their children their
husbands
and doing so publicly of course but
trying to
dress it up like it's an insight it's
really not it's just one long complaint
one complaint after another
but it's supposed to be supposed to be
insightful somehow
exhibit a we have this article which has
been getting shared on social media a
lot the past few days
from the mommy blog scarymommy.com
this was actually written a little while
ago but uh you know there's
there's no statute of limitations on
cancellations as we have learned
so i'm still gonna cancel this
and all mommy blogs because of it the
title is my daughter is hard to like
and i'm sorry all right here's here's a
little bit of the
thing it says uh the day that i realized
my child is that child was a turning
point for me as a mother
it's the day i started to feel ashamed
of my daughter and the way she behaves
the day i started to wonder if there was
something wrong with her or with me
as the one who gave birth to her and is
responsible for making her to a decent
human being
yes bingo you know i think she see right
at the top there she stumbles on the
truth
there is something wrong with her but
then she proceeds to talk
to go on for 2 000 more words talking
about her daughter not herself
she says it happened on a day like any
other we were having a play date at our
house with friends
whom we know very well and have invited
over countless times before my
five-year-old and her four-year-old
friend
were running laps around the couch
playing tag my daughter was it and when
she couldn't catch up to her friend she
collapsed on the ground pouting close to
tears and shouted
i can't catch you you have to slow down
you have to i won't play anymore if you
don't
and i looked at her with a sigh as i
always do at times like this
and i looked at her friend who was
almost always smiling agreeable and
that's when i knew i knew that a
hypothesis
that had been building in my head and my
heart for months and months now was
unequivocally true
my child is not easy to like well i
think part of the problem here is that
your child's acting like a brat in
public and acting out and your response
is just to sigh
you're just staring there you're staring
at her as your as your child
has a temper tantrum just going oh geez
here she goes again what are you gonna
do
well you could do something you're the
mother
and it wasn't because of that one event
it was because that wasn't an isolated
event at all things like that happen all
the time
all the bloody time whether she is alone
with her siblings or with her friends or
at home or in public
my daughter is the bossy one the
demanding one the one making a scene at
the store as she cries on and on and on
because i won't let her buy a gymnastics
leotard
she is quick to cry yell throw the kind
of tantrum that i once thought only
two-year-olds were capable of
she's disrespectful and rude she's moody
unable to share and overly concerned
about every damn
toy uh insistent upon doing things her
way impossible if things don't go her
way manipulative
always thinking only of herself and
always prepared to tell you exactly what
she thinks and feels in that very moment
if she doesn't like what you are doing
you will hear about it
um on and on i mean just just a
long oh my goodness it's a long list
this is a long indictment that this
woman is publishing about her
five-year-old
um and she says later on she says for
those of you who encounter my darling
big-eyed brat
you will be forgiven if you don't like
her i often don't like her myself
i am her mother and i love her because i
have enjoyed her at her best i recognize
her potential
i know her strengths and then it goes on
and on
as women tend to do and finally at the
end of it she pleads
that for the public to help her parent
by straightening her daughter out with
peer pressure
she actually tries to solicit peer
pressure against her daughter
because she's given up on actually
parenting okay
a few things here first of all you
shouldn't love your child
for their potential you're supposed to
love them
period just to love them because you're
the parent
loving your child for her potential is a
problem because what if she never lives
up to
the potential your idea of her potential
are you going to stop loving her i guess
so apparently so second your child is a
reflection of you
okay which which isn't to say that a
child who acts out
you know or whatever or misbehaves
always has a bad parent
that would be ridiculous of course all
kids act out all five-year-olds are
varying degrees of difficult
um kids also have their own minds and
personalities and you can only
do so much to control them um and kids
will go through especially difficult
phases at one point or another i think
it's probably different for all kids
you hear about the terrible twos you
know in my my wife and i talk all the
time about
we never really experienced that two for
us is a pretty easy age
three becomes the difficult age um so
it's more
you know three is more of the it's the
terrible threes more than the terrible
twos
but it's different for every kid in
every family that said if your child
is an absolute terrorist then yes you're
doing something horribly wrong
most likely in the child raising
department
to dislike them to dislike your own
child is
not only pretty horrible in its own
right but it misses the point
if you're going to dislike anyone you
should dislike yourself they're taking
cues
from you okay this isn't happening in a
vacuum
kids can often be a mirror
reflecting ourselves back to us and that
can often be the most difficult thing
about them
um in fact i find that the aspects of my
children's personalities that are the
hardest for me to deal with
are the aspects that are exactly like my
own personality stubbornness
temper absent-mindedness you know all of
that
that's me um being disorganized you know
another thing
uh that's that's how i am that's my kids
uh am i gonna resent them for what
failing to be a better person than me
failing to be more mature than i am
that's that's absurd
but i really think that's a lot of the
anger that parents experience at their
kids
is is this now they don't think of it
like this
but a lot of the time they're angry at
their kids
for failing to be better than themselves
they hold their kids to a higher
standard than they hold themselves
and on the outside for outsiders it's
always easy to identify
um so i don't know what the first thing
about this woman but i i'm willing to
bet
if i if we you know if you knew her and
you saw her kid
all the ways her kids acting you would
say oh yeah well that's exactly how the
mom is
it's no surprise at all um bossy
bratty you know always have to have your
way materialistic
i'm betting that the mom is exactly like
that yet here she is
proving that she's in fact a lot worse
than her kid because she resents her
child for doing all the same stuff she
does
i mean if you do it how could you
possibly expect your kid not to do it
that's not fair to them
that we we have to understand the
limitations of a child which is another
challenging
challenge of parenting to understand a
kid's limitations
and to work within those limitations and
to not expect
more than what is possible
if you're expecting your child to be
better than you
and to um to to
you know be more virtuous than you and
more mature
and to overcome personality defects
that you have not overcome well then you
are expecting too much of your child and
you have no right to do that
straighten yourself out first
because the main thing is with kids you
know and this is this is nothing
radical or revolutionary but
they they 90 of what they learn they
learn not based on what you say to them
but just based on copying what you do
so if you want them to act a certain way
then exhibit
that behavior show them what it's
if you never show them it's like all
these parents walking around
and all parents lapse into it sometimes
i know i do
at times i but i always try to catch
myself it's but it's the dumbest thing
when parents are mad at their kids
for not acting in a way that they the
parents
have never demonstrated okay you want
your kid to be a certain way
show them how don't just tell them don't
just stand there i demand that you be
better than this
be better i demand it for some reason it
doesn't resonate with a five-year-old
show them demonstrate and they'll copy
you
if you're not doing that there's no hope
if you're not even trying to demonstrate
good behavior to your child
then your child's gonna be a brat and
you know what it's not their fault it's
your fault
you have no right to be angry at them
you really don't
100 your fault um and then finally
third you know uh even aside from all
this however your kid acts brat or not
you really don't need to put this online
these are things that you save
for your therapist or um your husband
god help him uh or you know a friend or
whatever but
you don't this this doesn't need to be
online for everybody
we don't all need to hear it uh but this
is what parents do now where they they
just they
vent about their kids on a public forum
you're venting about your child to
millions of people and your child one
day is going to grow up and read that
themselves
and see what an utterly insufferable
selfish
whiny petty brat you were
um which maybe will be helpful for them
to see that and then you know they can
start to recover and heal themselves
but but even so i i would say it's
probably better just to keep all that
crap to yourself
we you know we we just we don't need to
hear it
and that's my advice but anyway mommy
bloggers are canceled anyway so you're
not gonna be
you can't say anything anymore online
because you're canceled
and that's it we'll leave it there
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton